[Music]
so sale Montreal is bringing fresh ideas
from South Korea I'm very excited about
the creation of sale which is a new
academic style research lab Pali located
within Mila which makes it very unique
we're hiring research scientists to do
open science in collaboration with the
Malenko system as well as visitors from
sate in Korea
what I expect is that there would be a
lot more research collaborations a lot
more exchanges events that will happen
that'll increase the amount of cool new
research that's being done by both labs
I hope that the collaboration with Mila
which actually started a few years ago
will will continue and I think on the
theoretical side Simonis is an amazing
researcher and he's recruiting very
strong theory people but I think the
collaboration also leads to practical
applications which otherwise we wouldn't
have a chance to do
a lot of companies have studied the lab
together with a Miele such as Microsoft
Google and all the other places but what
we see is that it those are all US
companies only and then what I believe
is that the sale which is the AI lab of
the Samsung advancing store technology
can bring another perspective I believe
this kind of diverse view is going to be
the thing that's going to make sale
really great and also merely great as
well so I hope that we the sale lab will
inspire us to to bring us do inside
[Music]
it's contributing to the AI hub in
Montreal the AI ecosystem is great to
have companies like Samsung that can
have a huge worldwide impact with their
products embedded in Mila
[Music]
[Applause]